I feel like a badass [ __ ] when I wear
my hijab hey the job is not just a piece
of cloth that we put on our head it's a
symbol to me about being seen for your
intelligence before you a beauty wearing
the hijab has made me unapologetic about
Who I am as a person when I started
wearing hijab I was scared of like
what's this person going to say I went
through 21 years of not wearing it
once I came to that realization that I
think that wearing the hijab will make
me a better person and hopefully help me
become the kind of person I want to be
in the future that's when I was like
nope I need to do this so I went in the
first day of sophomore year of high
school with I remember it like a bright
pink ajob I was actually encouraged by
other people and relatives to take it
off and not wear it so it was my choice
to put it on and it was my decision to
practice this part of my faith well my
mother was very much against me wearing
the hijab because my parents are both
Muslims but they're from Iran and over
there wearing a hijab is something that
is enforced among everybody it is a
political tool where I put my religious
beliefs out there and possibly be harmed
it's unfortunate that people have this
negative opinion about the job people
who think that the hijab oppresses women
but I mean I hope to be an example that
I'm not an oppressed woman who wears the
hijab I had to keep explaining that this
is not about trying to prove what a good
Muslim I am whether you wear hijab or
not is between you and God
it is no one's place to judge I don't
care if you're a stripper at night and
you wear hijab during the day that is
your business you wear hijab on your
terms honey and that's what I do when I
go up onstage I open my
and I perform I definitely shock people
because I'm the only one where any job
that gets up on these public open mics
and they have the stereotypical thing
when I walk in like oh what is that
person doing here and then all of a
sudden my up there on stage and I'm
performing about a breakup or a
relationship or death or divorce or
things like that and people are like oh
she's human like surprise we are I have
changed the way I look to represent Who
I am and because my identity is so out
there and I have to embrace it and I
have to embrace that yes sometimes I'm
going to be looked at and get questions
you have no choice but to become more
confident about about it because you are
wearing your identity on your sleeve I
do identify myself as a feminist and so
I do write a lot about social issues and
cultural issues that transcend all these
barriers and the fact that I'm speaking
up about these things in a hijab it
breaks that stereotype to
you know like the introverted
domesticated submissive kind of woman
when know we have a water outspoken very
strong independent females who do
practice this part of the faith it's
awesome that earlier this year
if the hajj muhammad went to the
olympics wearing the hijab as a fencer
there representing the US team and it
just goes to show again that she wasn't
there because she wore her job she was
there because she is good at what she
does and honestly whenever I see any
Muslim woman and hey jobs doing amazing
things making it to magazine covers and
and succeeding in different elements of
like cooking or baking or fashion or
Business and Finance it's it's a huge
empowering feeling it's an inspiration
you see and you feel like yeah someone
else could do it so can I so I'm going
to keep doing what I do
practicing my faith the way that I am I
see women sexualized to the core I see
women having to feel validation from how
they look and I have struggled through
trying to seek that validation through
how I look as well and to cover my hair
and to have everything covered to me is
a symbol of I want nothing to do with
that for myself and I am taking my booty
back with the rise of social media you
see that there's not just one weight or
a woman who wears hijab to look you can
have so many different styles having
that opportunity to do fun stuff with
our hijab is really nice to be able to
like add colors and add sparkles and
wrap it certain ways so that we get to
express our feelings of beauty in in a
certain way as well